muy buenos días pues en realidad los
homenajes a diego armando maradona
continúan y van a continuar por mucho
tiempo porque esta ciudad vive
difícilmente este duelo los siguen
llorando y seguramente lo van a llorar
durante muchos años como usted lo decía
así es la gente estuvo en el estadio
hasta pasada la medianoche de este
viernes dejando banderines dejando
banderas mensajes ahora estamos aquí a
las afueras de nápoles aquí en este
lugar el club nápoli saverio vignatti y
aquí en realidad hay uno de los más
grandes tesoros que pueda tener esta
ciudad y es que hay exactamente como un
museo dedicado a maradona con cientos de
objetos unos más increíbles que los
otros objetos que el astro argentino
utilizó cuando vivió aquí en annápolis
cuando llegó aquí entre en 1984 y antes
de que se fuera aquí de aquí de nápoles
en 1991
natalia de cómo va el proceso del cambio
de nombre del estadio de la polis que
pasará a tener el nombre del astro
argentino
pues es un proceso que va a tomar un
poco de tiempo porque en realidad según
a la ley italiana se necesita que la
persona haya muerto diez años hayan
pasado diez años de la muerte de una
persona para que un sitio para que un
monumento un lugar pues se lleve el
nombre de esta persona puede ser que
este proceso se ha acelerado en todo
caso pareciera que las autoridades aquí
quieren que así sea en todo caso tanto
el presidente de la club del napoli del
nápoles como el alcalde de la ciudad que
nunca se han podido entender entre ellos
en lo político en este caso si han
encontrado un digamos han encontrado que
están de acuerdo en cuanto a esto en
cuanto a que el estadio sampaoli pues
pase a llamarse estadio diego armando
maradona por ahora no hay digamos unos
tiempos de cuánto va a durar este
proceso seguramente va a ser acelerado
porque lo que sí es cierto es que todos
a una polis tanos quieren que este
estadio lleve el nombre de su héroe